This is a brine shrimp.
As it moves through the water it
creates swirling eddies behind it.
A single shrimp only moves a tiny
amount of water. But in a large group,
could creatures like these move enough
water to influence the mixing of an ocean?
To find out, research has kept groups of
brine shrimp in tall tanks in their lab.
Then they suspended tiny particles in the  water
which they could track to analyze its flow.
By shining a light from the top of the tank
they could cause the swarm to swim up,
mimicking the natural migratory
behaviour of other shrimp like krill.
And as they rose something
surprising happened.
Together the shrimp produced a jet of
water as large as the swarm itself,
forcing water down as they swam up.
A decade ago scientists didn't think this
kind of aggregation effect was possible,
but this research shows that it can happen
and according to the researchers
on a large enough scale to impact the climate.
You see brine shrimp are only a model
organism but the researchers think
that this phenomenon might also happen
with critters like krill, which live in
climatically sensitive areas like the
Southern Ocean.
Water jets on the scale of swarms of krill,
which can get large enough to see from space,
could have major impacts
on ocean mixing.
Changing the balance of ocean chemistry,
nutrient flows and even the climate.
Now this effect has only been seen in a lab
and predictions about its impacts
are mostly speculation
But if confirmed in field studies it could
represent an entirely new role played by
some of the most abundant animals on the planet.
Not to mention oceanographers would
have a brand new variable to add to their models.